richten wir jetzt unseren blick auf
einen rummel in berlin-neukölln
eigentlich ein ort der freude am
samstagabend wird er zum tatort gegen 23
uhr kommt es zu einer auseinandersetzung
zwischen mehreren personen und am ende
ist ein mann tot laut bild informationen
handelt es sich bei dem opfer um
mohammed ein hochrangiges mitglied eines
berliner clans
messer mord auf dem jahrmarkt tatort
berlin neukölln
auf einem berliner volksfest kommt es am
samstagabend zu einer auseinandersetzung
zwischen mehreren personen plötzlich
bricht ein mann mit stichverletzungen
zusammen wenig später ist er tot die
täter flüchten können nicht gefasst
werden das opfer mohammad r 25 jahre alt
und hochrangiges mitglied eines berliner
klar die einsatzkräfte und die in zu
gerufenen rettungskräfte haben die
person unter reanimation bedingungen in
ein krankenhaus transportieren müssen wo
der junge mann mittlerweile verstorben
ist während die ärzte vergebens um das
leben des mannes kämpfen belagern 200
angehörige des opfers ebenfalls aus dem
klaren milieu das krankenhaus es muss
massiv von der polizei geschützt werden
und nun
[Musik]
mohammed er ist nicht der erste tote in
berlins blutigem klaren krieg vor drei
jahren wird der bruder von mohammed
nidal auf dem tempelhofer feld in berlin
erschossen am helllichten tag vor den
augen seiner familie in nidda list zur
damaligen zeit einer der bekanntesten
kriminellen aus dem berliner clown
milieu entsprechend groß ist seine
beerdigung sie würde zum schaulaufen
arabisch stämmiger großfamilien 2000
personen erscheinen darunter die
oberhäupter bekannter klar
obwohl die morde an mohammed und nidal
nicht aufgeklärt sind eines scheint
sicher die täter sind mitglieder anderer
arabisch stämmiger großfamilien die
gründe für den kleinkrieg sollen banal
sein es geht um ehre und rache nidal
soll bei einer großen hochzeitsfeier das
mitglied einer anderen großfamilie
beschimpft und zusammengeschlagen haben
dafür muss er wenig später sterben jetzt
fällt auch noch sein bruder mohammed der
blutfehde zum opfer der tod der beiden
brüder ist womöglich nicht das letzte
kapitel in berlins kleinkrieg
[Musik]
nicht die einzige bluttat in berlin an
diesem wochenende denn bereits am
freitag tötete ein 42 jähriger afghane
seine ex-frau mit einem jagdmesser
bestialischer mord mitten in berlin und
das auf offener straße am hellichten tag
am freitagmorgen lauert ein 42 jähriger
afghane seiner ex frau vor einem
flüchtlingsheim auf und metzelt sie auf
bestialische weise nieder er sticht der
wehrlosen mutter in dem bauch schneidet
ihr anschließend die kehle durch die
tatwaffe ein 30 zentimeter langes
jagdmesser das opfer die 31-jährige zur
ag sie verstirbt noch am tatort
hinterlässt sechs kinder die sie
zusammen mit dem täter hat
familienangehörige des opfers berichten
der täter hat seine ex frau in den
letzten wochen immer wieder bedrängt
zweimal soll er sie in dieser zeit
verprügelt haben am freitag ermordet er
sie sofort nach der barbarischen tat
flüchtete der afghane nur um wenig
später erneut an den ort des schreckens
zurückzukehren dort kann die polizei den
brutalen mörder überwältigen und
festnehmen unfassbar bei diesen
barbarischen tathergang der richter
sieht keine anzeichen für einen mord
weder mordlust noch heimtücke kommen für
ihn als motiv in frage er steckt den
täter nur wegen totschlags in u haft
unfassbar darüber müssen wir natürlich
sprechen bild reporter ralf schuler ist
bei uns im studio ralf also wie kann man
das verstehen da ersticht ein mann seine
ex frau auf offener straße quasi und es
ist kein einziges mordmerkmal dabei
erfüllt wie geht das das ist die sonder
welt der juristerei es gibt bestimmte
merkmale die erfüllt sein müssen wir
haben gerade gehört heimtücke oder
mordlust ich als objektiver beobachter
hätte beides hier auch durchaus in
anrechnung gebracht der richter offenbar
nicht das gehört zu den geheimnissen
auch der berliner justiz und niedere
beweggründe hätte man mal anbringen
können nicht also einfach nur bei der
ehemann hat vier jahre gedauert also hat
also heimtücke wäre da schon am platze
gewesen ist es nicht wirklich zu
verstehen aber
vor gericht und auf hoher see ist man
bekanntlich in gottes hand und
ist man tut der sache einfach nichts
gutes hier in berlin weil solche taten
ja nicht die ersten sind und ist seiner
tagesordnung wenn man dass die botschaft
nicht sendet dass das ein regelverstoß
ist der mit härteren mitteln geahndet
wird dann muss man sich nicht wundern
wenn diese szene immer weiter zulauf
bekommt immer weiter zulauf ist auch ein
gutes stichwort weil polizei und politik
schaffen es ja auch nicht diese klaren
kriminalität zu stoppen wenn man noch
mal auf diesen plan fall zu sprechen
kommen woran liegt das dass da nicht
mehr gemacht wird das hat verschiedene
gründe einmal gibt es eine gewisse
beißhemmung der justiz und der behörden
weil man sich nicht
ausländerfeindlichkeit nachsagen lassen
möchte das ist immer wieder eine
begründung die man die man da hört es
gibt sogar eine innenpolitiker
arbeitsgruppe der berliner spd die das
wort plan streichen möchte wir sehen das
dann an so verdrucksten meldungen wie
zwei großfamilien gehen im wedding
aufeinander zu und jeder weiß es sind
nicht die müllers und die schulz ist
damit tut man der sache keinen gefallen
das andere problem ist dass die justiz
lange zeit
gesucht hat nach mitteln wie man gegen
vor allem die schattenwirtschaft die
diese clans betreiben vorgehen können
und nordrhein westfalen ist ein ganz
gutes beispiel der innenminister reul
dort geht mit aller härte gegen diese
szene vor und er nutzt eben auch
unkonventionelle mittel der tausend
nadelstiche jeden tag eine
hygienekontrolle das problem ist einfach
wenn man eine shisha war illegal
betreibt weiß man nicht mit bargeld
eingenommen worden ist und ob dann nicht
geldwäsche betrieben wird es wird immer
wieder kontrolliert es wird auf allen
gesellschaftlichen ebenen versucht
wirklich hart dran zu bleiben und dann
kann man das auch machen es ist in eine
schattenwelt in die man auch so ohne
weiters nicht eindringt aber der wille
muss erst einmal da sein und der fehlt
in berlin seit jahren jetzt haben wir
auf berlin geschaut aber wie groß ist
denn das problem in ganz deutschland
allgemein also nordrhein westfalen und
berlin sind die beiden hochburgen und
seit herbert reul in nordrhein westfalen
das wirklich ganz massiv offen und
erklärtermaßen angegangen ist kommen die
nicht so schnell zur ruhe das problem
ist aber ein viel tiefer gehendes wenn
wir
die migration jedes jahr weit über die
grenzen haben letztes jahr sind etwa 180
tausend menschen eingereist einfach über
die grenze gekommen haben sich dann
später gemeldet dann fühlen wir gerade
auch prekäre milieus immer wieder auf
weil natürlich nur leute aus der heimat
sind kommen gerne auch andere hin und es
gibt dann diese schattenwirtschaft wo
man auch schnell mal einen job bekommt
nur eben mit integration hat das alles
nichts zu tun und in neukölln und zum
teil auch in kreuzberg führen einige
dieser großfamilien dann doch
ängstigen das eigenleben man hat selbst
ganze jahrgänge in der polizeischule in
berlin festgestellt dass die einer
großfamilie angehört und sich für den
polizeidienst ausbilden lassen wollten
ganz seltsame umtriebe und das bedeutet
nichts gutes für die entwicklung in der
hauptstadt du hast heute im kommentar in
ein bild kommentar auch geschrieben dass
das intern neben kein gewinnerthema ist
in der politik das anzugehen woran liegt
das das problem ist ich habe es schon
erwähnt die im illegale migration die ja
die werte der union richtig nach unten
gezogen hat die grünen und die spd sind
für migration sie möchten allerdings
fachkräfte einwanderung haben wer
illegal kommt das kann man schwer
steuern und die ampel koalition möchte
jetzt auch noch den spurwechsel so
kommst du sagst du willst asyl dann
bekommst du kein asyl weil du aus
tunesien kommt und kann es dann wechseln
als als verkäufer wenn man die migration
nicht anfängt zu steuern dann kommen
halt immer leute die sich irgendwo in
der schattenwirtschaft verdingen und bei
den parteien ist das hochgradig
unbeliebt mit abschiebung macht man sich
keine freunde mit dem sichern von
grenzen macht man sich keine freunde
oder ist verstößt sogar gegen
ideologische grundsätze gerade bei den
grünen und deshalb lässt man das problem
einfach unangetastet auch mit der
begründung es nützt nur den falschen
macht die afg stark wenn man das problem
benennt also benennt man das problem
erst gar nicht und hofft dass es sich
irgendwie weg drückt
keine gute entwicklung der hanke schön
ralf schuler für deine einstellung